I wanted to make a film about kind of
the last town and I got interested in
what was at the very very bottom of the
road in Louisiana all the way out in the
marsh and I started driving down to the
end of every road and when I got down to
this town called ile de Jean Charles I
drove down that tiny little road that
you see in the last shot of the film and
you get to this place that's completely
isolated from the world and going
through a lot of the things that are
happening in the film and so I sort of
started with that and then at the same
time was working on Lucy's play and you
can maybe talk a little bit about where
that comes from it was about a child
named hush puppy who because it was so
close to my heart was a little boy I
wrote it about my my relationship with
my dad after he got very sick and was I
was dealing with my dad's mortality for
the first time and it was so personal to
me that I just couldn't make it about
myself so I made I made it a little boy
and we switched it back to a girl we
switched it back to in bed and I in our
first meeting I think he says this is a
little girl
this is Hush Puppies a little girl and
I'm so grateful that he did that
audition was something that you would
never expect for audition my mom's
friend just like called and said they
had an audition at the library that was
for six to nine year olds and I was only
five so I just went to see if I could
get to try but in the middle of that my
mom was like she could not go she's too
young and my mom's ranma's like you sure
about that one so it was just something
that it was just like a try for so we
just went away like we just went and did
something that five-year-old wouldn't do
so we just went and tried and they call
back like two days later and said they
had audition well they had like a
callback and the person who was on the
phone with Michael got walk one of the
producers and he say he was looking for
naazy my mom was a nice
see you must be looking for Chris and me
they were like oh no he was like oh no
we must have caught the wrong person my
mom was like she stopped her and she
said wait I know my my daughter audition
so you must she must did you answer her
name or did you read it off with a sheet
and they were Michael was like we asked
her name that's why she must have told
you nazy but that's her nickname and her
real name is convincing me so he was
like oh yes we're looking for Nazy so it
was something that a five year old
wouldn't like they were just they would
just react to what they say and it was
just something at my young age I would
just answer what a dog says whenever
they called and said I had the part I
was just like a normal kid on a computer
and they just call and I was like yes
and I went right back to the computer
prefer a part we looked at over 4,000
kids over the course of about nine
months and the way that we work is you
know the we don't sort of finish the
script and then cast the film and then
location scout the film we try to do all
those things at the same time so it
gives us an ability to kind of
incorporate the people that were casting
into the roles and sort of it becomes an
almost research project so you know for
Dwight's character we actually met
Dwight because he runs a bakery that was
directly across the street from our
casting office and so we be in there in
the morning you know getting doughnuts
and coffee and hanging out with Dwight
and you know we actually thought that we
were gonna have to cast that role
professionally because of how difficult
it was but he came in on a whim one day
and you know as we sort of work with and
we started to see that we actually had
someone that was gonna be able to rise
to the occasion and actually bring his
life to this character in a way that was
so much more visceral than anything we'd
seen with with any of the actors we were
working with the BP oil spill happened
on day one of our shoot and it was sort
of approaching this town where we were
the whole time and so when we were
driving through that town and sort of
you know creating the story moment it
felt like that that was being reflected
in life at the same time and so there
was a real kind of
you know our boat drivers were hearing
that their their fishing their talent
the fishing in their town was gonna be
shut down for ten years and there was
like a somberness to that day that kind
of bled into the shoot so there's things
like that were you know the elements you
know hopefully infused themselves into
the into the screen it was just like a
lot of words like why don't say it and
it was I was like okay speed rolling and
action things like that was so unusual
[Applause]